make sure your home is wheelchair
accessible and get out your headbang
counters because Netflix's secret
obsession is friggin ridiculous it's
crazy it's crazy now I don't know about
you but when I was watching this I got a
total lifetime made-for-tv-movie vibe
you know the kind made for stay-at-home
moms will they drink an entire bottle of
wine and lo and behold check out the
credits for the writer director of this
film it's all just made-for-tv movies so
let's throw reality out the window and
dive into this crazy mess of a movie I'm
gonna start with a little dissection of
the ending and then point out the dozens
of plot holes inconsistencies and just
straight-up weird [ __ ] I found in this
movie secret obsession ends with the
death of Russel Williams or has he's
known around the office Ryan Garrity
he's taken over Russell's identity after
murdering him and takes Jennifer his
obsession along with him but Jennifer
escapes and this is where the movie
actually begins the first five minutes
is Jennifer being chased by a
knife-wielding assailant who we never
see it's only until later in the movie
that we find out this man is a crazy
co-worker obsessed with her Bryan spent
years longing for Jennifer creepily
watching her with Russell from afar his
boss even said Bryan had a temper and
was later fired from work for fracturing
the nose of one of his managers it was
likely after this event Ryan went on a
killing spree murdering anyone close to
Jennifer including her parents and
husband Russell after all if he can't
have her no one can but something
miraculous happened as he tells Jennifer
God gave him a second chance
after Jennifer's run over by a car
during her escape she loses her memory
and who comes to her rescue none other
than Bryan who has taken Russell's
identity he has even put on his glasses
and holds an engraved lighter from
Jennifer with the words - my darling
Russell loved Jennifer since Jennifer
can't remember anything she kind of just
goes along with it and the hospital
allows Ryan to take her home because he
ID'd the tattoo in her back and had
pictures that they were husband and wife
now the tattoo
would have known about either from
working with her for so long or simply
because he's a mega stalker the photos
on the other hand are a whole other deal
apparently Ryan is a Photoshop master
and is digitally replaced Russell in all
of Jennifer's photos with himself this
is something Jennifer picks up on while
looking through old photo albums
Ryan's hair doesn't match that of the
mirrors reflection it's only until later
when she snoops around in Ryan's
computer that she finds the original
photo which leads me to one of my
biggest criticisms of the film Ryan is
the stupidest killer ever
first of all besides the fact that his
computer which has all the incriminating
evidence on it is in plain sight the
password for it is Jennifer Allen her
real name and she just guesses it huh
that was easy
second of all all these photos are
stored in a folder called private come
on bro if you're gonna hide [ __ ] on your
computer at least put it in a folder
called taxes or something but Bryan's
incompetence and in some cases insanity
doesn't stop there
we're just getting started Ryan who
moments prior failed that kidnapping
Jennifer goes to the hospital without
even knowing she's lost her memory
anything not only that but this is where
he starts posing as Russell as evidenced
in the security camera footage of him
putting on these glasses how did he know
she had lost her memory before the
doctors even did but what are the most
insane Ryan moments is when he
straight-up murders someone on their own
front lawn cracking their neck Steven
Seagal style while a neighbor's mere
feet away it gets better he buries the
body at night in plain view for Jennifer
to see and later when she escapes and
trips in the garden his hand is clearly
visible like dude you realize you need
to bury the body under the ground right
oh and what can I help you with that
Home Depot today sir oh you know just a
giant sack of lye so we know Ryan has
made efforts to bury this random dudes
body get Jennifer a new phone change the
sign outside the house but doesn't
bother to dispose of Jennifer's parents
or Russell who's still in his trunk he
himself is even disgusted by the smell
when he opens the garage long story
short he's terrible at covering his
tracks we also have Ryan with his
security camera on Jennifer but that's
only brought up once and never comes
up again so it's really kind of
pointless not only that he's just sloppy
giving a fake address to the hospital
not showing up to the meeting he planned
with the detective and my personal
favorite cutting the Internet's router
like you couldn't have just thrown out
the cable you had to cut it like you're
a bomb defuser and Hurt Locker let's not
also forget that he's terrible at
locking people up
not only does Jennifer get out three
times once with a hairpin second because
he didn't tie her up properly and third
with a lighter but he just locks
detective Paige in a freezer with no
real lock or weight put on top of it but
it's not just Ryan's actions that make
no sense there are countless examples of
the plot completely riding off the rails
we have detective page in one scene
downing a bottle of prescription pills
but we never know what those are for or
how it affects him if anything it's
about the disappearance of his daughter
who he makes presents for every year and
somehow saving Jennifer he's able to
overcome this and decides to donate all
the toys but it's so contrived and
barely touched on that the emotional
pull of it is hardly noticeable just
like how there's one brief shot of him
looking at a retirement pamphlet in the
beginning and then one line at the end
that he's finally ready to retire these
things need to be built up over the
entire movie for them to feel genuine
and real not just put in once at the
beginning and one at the end and going
okay that character changed I also don't
understand why her tattoo says a to
represent her last name Alan in Gaelic
writing I don't know about you guys but
I've never seen an all-asian family with
the last name Alan wait is he Caucasian
let's solve this mystery in the comments
below all right I know I shat on this
movie a lot but honestly I thought it
was just that kind of bad that made it
kind of good you know so if you're
desperate and want to laugh and want to
shut your brain off for a bit check out
secret obsession I only watch this thing
once and I'm sure there are like a
hundred different potholes so if you
found any let me know in the comments
below and let me know what you thought
about it also make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and follow me on twitter at
things story whitey until next time
remember daddy loves you very much